if you kept a close eye on your screen
through one division's first and second
episodes
you would have noticed some suspicious
details that tie into one another
no no not that whatever mr hart was
choking on looked like a chocolate
covered strawberry
or that the actress who plays mrs
foreman from that 70s show hasn't aged
in the last 20 years
we're talking about the fact that in a
handful of instances across one division
episodes one and two
a very specific piece of iconography
poked its head up a hilted blade in a
circle
certified marvel nerds will have
recognized this emblem it's the logo for
sword the cloak and dagger sister
organization to shield
as one division carried on into its
third episode sword's presence continued
to loom large
though it wasn't clear how exactly the
organization was involved in wonder and
vision strange suburban world in one
division episode 4 the curtain didn't
just get pulled back
it was practically torn to shreds the
episode reveals that monica rambo who
had been masquerading inside west
viewers wonder and vision's neighbor
geraldine
works as a sword agent i actually don't
know what i'm doing here
i'm starting to feel that way myself she
was one of the billions of people who
were erased in the blip that happened in
avengers infinity
war and her first mission back at sword
is to partner with agent jimmy wu
to investigate westview new jersey the
site of a missing person's case
sword swiftly moves into action by
constructing an observation base
outside westview tasking astrophysicist
dr darcy lewis
and jimmy with monitoring the goings-ons
of the town and sending moniker in as an
agent of infiltration
despite darcy and jimmy's best efforts
they can't get in contact with wonder
via radio
things go from confusing to alarming
when monika
presumably trying to get wanda to
realize she's living in a fake reality
brings up the fact that wanda's twin
brother pietro dies at the hands of
ultron
wonder sends monica flying out of view
and when she opens her eyes surrounded
by sword agents
monika tells them that this is all
wander's doing well sword might not
boast a decade's worth of brand
recognition that you get from nick
fury's favorite 9-5
the organization is a natural fit for
film and television
in fact the sword's comic book origins
are rooted in the same source
that brought the avengers together on
the big screen for the first time
even more excitingly their addition to
the marvel cinematic universe
could foreshadow the reintroduction of
one of marvel's most beloved ips
but let's not get ahead of ourselves the
story of marvel's sword organization
goes back to 2004 several years before
joss whedon wrote
and directed the avengers at the time
whedon was the lead writer on
astonishing x-men a re-imagining of the
mutant team that shifted them away from
the black leather paramilitary vibe
they've been rocking during the grand
morrison years and back to the world of
more colorful super heroics
spandex was back in style whedon's
trademark quips riddled the page and the
occupants of the xavier school were back
to their favorite pastime
getting harassed by aliens that's where
sword came in originally standing for
sentient world observation and response
department that'll be important in a
minute
the organization was in practice shield
in space
the multi-species organization operated
out of a weaponized satellite orbiting
planet earth
and did pretty much what it saves on the
bottle they observed sentient wells and
when necessary
responded to them basically any threat
to earth that you couldn't reach with a
shield heli carrier
fell under sword's purview so there are
a couple of reasons that sword's
inclusion in one division
should be making nerd's hearts race the
first is marvel studios recent reveal
that sword stands for something
distinctly different
in the marvel cinematic universe the
second is the laundry list of specific
characters generally associated with the
organization
specifically the x-men having debuted in
an x-men title and worked alongside
marvel's merry mutants so frequently
sword is inexorably linked to the team
in the marvel comics a half alien half
mutant named abigail brand
is a person who runs sword and the
organization has included familiar names
like beast
cable and magneto all of this could tie
pretty neatly into that name change we
mentioned earlier
prior to the series release on disney
plus some fans noticed a one division
themed digital trading card set
included an interesting detail
apparently the w in sword stands for
weapon in the
mcu not world one division episode iv
confirmed this name change
when text on the screen tells viewers
are now watching action taking place at
the headquarters
of the sentient weapon observation and
response department
this implies what the group's wheelhouse
is now one of two things
either those cartoon bullets from who
framed roger rabbit
or folks with inherent abilities that
make them a perceived threat
gosh that sounds like mutants longtime
fans will know that wanda maximoff and
her brother pietro had the origin
stories
how do we put this lovingly enhanced in
order to bring them into the mcu
we haven't enhanced in the field
originally the maximoff twins were a
pair of mutants
while everything in the marvel universe
with an ex-adjacent story
was legally out of bounds for disney
which owns marvel
the siblings association with the
avengers made them fair game
albeit with all that mutation business
scrubbed off now that the house of mouse
has acquired nearly all [ __ ]
properties
mutants are back on the menu could a
government department dedicated to
dealing with living weapons add up to
the long-awaited introduction of the
x-men to the mcu
we don't want to speak out of turn but
maybe
what the sh that's the coolest name ever
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]